[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing none other than famed
magi zoologist newt scamander in the
form
of his patronus animal newt is of course
the author
of fantastic beasts and where to find
them a very popular book in the magical
world
outlining all sorts of magical creatures
it's essentially an encyclopedia of
magical creatures
and lists everything that you need to
know about these beasts
newt gathered his information over years
of scouring the globe
and once described his profession as
follows i have visited lairs
burrows and nests across five continents
observed the curious habits of magical
beasts in a hundred countries
witnessed their powers gained their
trust and
on occasion beaten them off with my
travelling kettle
newt's book was so well received by the
wizarding population
that it was even made an integral part
of the hogwarts curriculum
by headmaster albus dumbledore newt's
masterpiece had been an approved
textbook at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
ever since his publication and must take
a substantial amount of credit
for our students consistently high
results in care of magical creatures
examinations
we're first introduced to newt scamander
in the new fantastic piece films
where he's one of the main characters
he's a calm mild-mannered man
with an astounding amount of patience
and an incredible attitude
toward dealing with animals he's highly
nurturing
very quirky and certainly awkward but he
has a certain charm about him
he's often barely able to make eye
contact with other people
and is sometimes painfully awkward but
his honest love for magical creatures
and his empathy and desire to help
others means that we can't help
but like him so if you're anything like
me you must be wondering
what is the patronus animal of a man who
is an affinity for so many different
creatures
in this video we're going to be
theorizing on what exactly newt's
patronus animal is and i think that he's
a particularly interesting subject to
analyze in this regard
because of his relationship with
creatures a patronus is of course the
result of a witch or wizard casting the
patronus charm
there are two types of patronus charms
corporeal and
incorporeal the more basic form of the
spell is the incorporeal patronus
which assumes no animal form and simply
resembles a burst of white vapour
or smoke and the more advanced form of
the spell is the conjuring of a
corporeal patronus
the ability to successfully cast a
is considered an impressive feat in the
wizarding community the corporeal
patronus assumes the form of the witch
or wizards
spirit animal and varies extensively
from wish to witch
or wizard to wizard while casting spells
that create your very own spirit animal
is probably fun
there is a purpose and that purpose is
to ward off dementors or blethovolds
dark creatures that feed on human
happiness and insight a feeling of
despair
and anyone that gets close to them they
are among the fathers creatures around
and represent nothing but darkness
depression and decay
the patronus charm is the only known way
of dealing with a dementor
and so it's a gravely important thing
for witch or wizard to know
the patronus represents everything that
dementor doesn't
hope happiness survival and purity as
the patronus itself does not feel
despair or
hopelessness as a human might the
dementors can't hurt it
and are repelled by its presence it's
also worth noting that each witch or
wizard that's actually able to produce a
corporeal patronus
will produce an animal that is uniquely
tied to them when initially casting the
corporeal patronus
the witch or wizard will have no idea
what animal they're conjuring
until they've done it for the first time
there is no explanation for how a
certain patronus animal
is tied to witch or wizard however it
has been heavily speculated
that the shape of the patronus produced
is significantly influenced by the
personality of the caster
and so when we see characters with the
same patronus harry and his father
snape and lily potter we can infer that
they had similar personality types
or a bond of some sort it's also worth
noting that the corporeal patronus of a
wizard
can actually change according to life
events a witch always is patronus animal
is a massively personal thing
and is often recognized as an extension
of their identity
in many cases you will even know who is
trying to contact you
through their patronus alone which can
actually be used like a messenger
there are almost no limits on what a
patronus can be
and this is well documented by professor
catalyst spangle
who also had this to say on patronuses
the patronus
asserted spangle represents that which
is hidden unknown
but not necessary within the personality
here says bengal
is the explanation for the appearance of
patronuses in forms that their casters
might not expect
for which they have never felt a
particular affinity or in rare cases
even recognize it is usual but not
inevitable
for a patronus to take the form of an
animal commonly found in the caster's
native country
given their long affinity with humans it
is perhaps unsurprising
but among the most common patronuses
although it must be remembered that any
corporeal patronus is highly unusual
our dogs cats and horses extinct
patronuses are very rare but not unknown
strangely given their long connection
with wizard kind
owl patronuses are unusual most uncommon
of all possible patronuses
are magical creatures such as dragons
destroys and phoenixes
while a rare and magical patronus
undoubtedly reflects an unusual
personality
it does not follow that it is more
powerful or will enjoy greater success
at defending its caster
a little while back actor eddie redmayne
who plays
newt's commander actually took the
patronus test himself
and had this to say i actually did the
patronus test
twice as it launched both times i got
the same patronus
the people from pottermore told me that
that was incredibly rare because of the
amount of algorithms it takes to choose
the patronus
so i must really be that thing it's then
revealed that redmayne's patronus is
a basset hound with long floppy ears so
that's redmayne but what about newt when
jk rowling was asked about newt's
patronus on twitter
all that she could say was that it would
be a big spoiler
this just makes me even more curious my
first
theory involves newt's relationship with
lifelong friend lito lestrange
lita and newt grew up together they both
attended hogwarts
and though lita ended up with newt's
brother theseus
they seemed to have a very unusual
relationship ever since childhood
there has been a certain tension between
them and i think that in the most recent
films
this tension is apparent on screen newt
may have found a new love interest in
tina goldstein but that doesn't suddenly
strip away the years and years
that newt and lita spent together they
were so close in fact
that newt remained in love with lita for
years after they parted ways
and even kept a framed photograph of her
in his workshed
as we see with snape and lily and harry
potter love
certainly plays a part in the role of
one's patronus and that's why snape
who shared a similar friendship with
lily and his youth had a patronus that
matched
lily's so in order to figure out what
newt's patronus is
we first need to figure out liters as jk
rowling always seems to place a certain
amount of emphasis
on etymology in harry potter i'm going
to dissect leader's name
to see if we can figure it out from
there it has been expressed that the
name
lita most likely originates from the
name leader
was the daughter of the italian king
thestius
she was anatolian princess who became a
spartan queen in greek mythology
and it just so happens that the most
popular fable surrounding leader
involved one particular animal a swan if
we assume
that newt's patronus matched liters out
of his love for her
then i think that it's reasonable to
assume that newt's patronus would also
be a swan what this would mean for
newt's relationship with tina goldstein
is unclear
but as patronuses can change i don't
think that it would be out of the
question
for us to witness news patronus changing
perhaps to later match tina's
my second and more conservative theory
is that newt's patronus is a hippogryph
here's why first things first
hippogriffs are very rare magical
creatures
half horse and half eagle we first see
them in the harry potter films when
hagrid introduces us to
buckbeak so far in fantastic beasts we
haven't seen them but if we dig just a
little bit into newt's past
it's easy for us to quickly make an
association you see
newt was born and raised in england and
his mother whose name we
don't actually know happened to be a
hippogriff breeder by profession
it was growing up with such majestic
creatures surrounding him that sparked
newt's initial interest in magical
creatures
hippogriffs were part of his
introduction to the world of beasts
and i think that it's reasonable to
assume that the positive associations
pertaining to his introduction to his
lifelong passion paired with the
thoughts of his mother would have some
sort of bearing on his patronus
and that's all i'm going to say for now
what do you guys think
what do you think new to patronus is do
either of my theories work for you
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard lowry
[Music]
you